i show some of my papers and they tell
me that i've been to court i've been
charged with
um
possession of three kilos of cocaine and
trying to export it out of the country i
am and i pleaded guilty to her and that
i've been sentenced to 10 years in
prison
[Music]
can you tell me what your childhood was
like
i had a difficult childhood um
my
parents were separated and
i my mom had
got married to
you know a different guy that wasn't my
father
and uh he was quite abusive
so i struggled um growing up and
eventually
um this ended up with me going into a
children's home
things still didn't carry on too too
well i was um abused by my social worker
in the children's home and um had a had
a child with with him
how old were you when that happened to
you
uh i was
i was 14 and he was 32
and then
i got pregnant when i was
16
and that's when when he lost his job
when i was pregnant the the council um
gave me a flat in a place called matson
in gloucester and yeah i had my own my
own two-bedroom flat
and um there was a local girl in there
in the village that was a quack addict
she noticed that i was on my own so she
just started coming around my friend my
flat every day and knocking on the door
and
dealers were giving her drugs to bring
around to share with me
so that i would get addicted and then
she her job then was to then when i did
have money and i did want to spend my
money she then took me to the dealers
and and that was it they you know they
had they had me then for the drug had me
then
what kind of drugs if crack crack
cooking
within two weeks two weeks i was just a
completely
different person you know my whole life
had changed how i felt about myself was
changing
um it was tough
and my addiction was just
it was out of control it
just totally consumed my life from
the moment i woke up
to the moment that i'd go to sleep which
sometimes could be you know days
every every day you know i was saying to
myself that you know the next day i
wouldn't smoke it and it was just going
around in circles
one of the dealers that i was um going
to and buying my drugs from
they asked me one day
um if i wanted to
um
go and get some if i wanted to get on a
plane and if i wanted to get some drugs
for them and
told me that they'd pay me some money
and pay for my holiday
so as well as seeing like money i saw it
as an opportunity to to get out to get
away i thought if i could just get out
of this area
and go away i could get clean and just
come back with a whole different
attitude you know and i'd be able to
come back and and have like loads of
money in my pocket and be like right i'm
not smoking you know i'm not going to
take drugs anymore
so how old were you about point of time
i think i was 19
yeah i was 19 around yeah around 19 at
the time
the the people that i was working for
were
they were masters in
you know their profession
and
they
i think i think they could clearly
identify in you know the the desperation
in me and the venerability
um and i think they honed in on that and
reassured me all the time they were
telling me that it you know it was good
that i was bringing my daughter
that nobody was ever gonna suspect me as
smuggling drugs with you know a young
child with me that nobody would ever
stop me and at that point in my life in
the stage where i was at and the things
that i was going through is just quite
you know and these people were being so
nice to me it was it was quite easy to
be you know sucked sucked into it
what was your first trip
um i went to holland
um
i was treated really nicely when i got
to holland there were some people there
waiting for me
i went to a flat
and the drugs were strapped to my waist
and i got on a boat and
and came back and it was all quite
smooth and quite easy and
and got paid my money
yeah i was keen to to do it again
what kind of drugs were you smuggling
cocaine
yeah smuggling cocaine back
which trip was your hardest
so venezuela was definitely the the
scariest
i went to this hotel and then the next
day this this guy turns up
and i didn't like him at all he he just
um i didn't have a good feeling about
him
just none of it
none of it felt felt good but i just
felt that i was
too far in i was too deep in i think i
was a little bit scared as well
you know to
to say to these people actually i don't
want to do this you know i didn't know
who
how
what they were capable of
he came there the day before i was going
he came and picked me up and told me to
bring my suitcase with me the suitcase
that i brought there with my stuff into
to empty it out
and that we were going to swap suitcases
and he gave me instructions for the next
day like he told me that um
the suitcase had the drugs in and
i was really nervous because it i could
i had a
full spot and he told me that you know
to open the suitcase up
and that it had a false bottom in it and
that the the drugs were hidden um in the
false bottom
so that if anyone opens a suitcase to
look at it you know there was still room
for my clothes and you and you couldn't
see the drugs
but i could i could smell the glue you
know it was almost like they'd just put
the the false bottom in like i don't
know an hour before they picked a
suitcase up or something you know and he
told me that um
the guardian were in on it he said you
know it's fine don't don't worry about
it
the the guardian at the airport you know
they know you'll come in
they know that your suitcase has got you
know drugs in there and they've been
paid off you know they're completely in
on air so i got to the airport still
terrified the whole time because i could
just smell this this suitcase and i
thought that
everybody else must be able to smell it
as well i get to the
airport
and i put the suitcase under suitcase
into the to the women from the travel
agency and even then i'm thinking she
must be able to smell this you know that
she must be able to smell the glue but
knowing it all goes through fine and i
get through to the departures lounge
and i'm sat there with my daughter and
i see the
i see the guardian come in and i enter
their the departure lounge
and um
heart sinks like i just know i know
straight away
that they're coming in for me that
they're looking for me they asked me to
go with them tell me to to follow them
well i assume that's what they're saying
you know they're talking spanish i can't
speak spanish then
but you know they made it quite clear
that
they wanted me to go with them i've got
no other choice but to tell myself this
is part of the plan this is part of the
plan you know you know when you're a kid
and you've done something wrong and you
just think you know if you squeeze your
eyes hard enough or if you wish it hard
enough you know you can turn back time
you know because you're still learning
aren't you that's that's how i felt you
know like it's gonna be okay
they take me into this room i've got
nikita with me and i'm trying to you
know say to her oh it's okay we're just
going here
and they take me into this room and um
my suitcase is on is on the table
and then i'm saying to myself okay maybe
they're just opening it you know to to
check that it all looks okay and then
this guardi pulls out it pulls out a
knife
and
for me in that in that moment that's
that is the moment when
i've kind of run out of options in my
head of being able to justify that this
is where it's going there's nothing left
i can say to be like this is supposed to
be happening happening that is
definitely not supposed to be happening
and um he's like took everything out of
my suitcase
and gets a knife and just like stabs the
stabs the knife
into the suitcase and with every
movement that he's making
i can just my my stomach is just sinking
more i'm more i'm more and more you know
with the realization that you know i've
been caught
they took me to like uh some
offices where there was like loads of
police and loads of guardian
um and then my suitcase was there and
they had the suitcase laid out with with
all the drugs laid out like next to it
with like laguardia they're having their
photos taken you know like so proud of
themselves they were you know it was
like they were like movie stars or
something posing for for a photo shoot
you know they were
like big grins on their face and
after that
i think i got
no i think i got taken to court
and somebody came and
picked up
my daughter you know i was told that she
was going to be taken to like an
orphanage and that there were lots of
children there and
you know
gardens and i just thought you know with
what was going on at the time
that
that was going to be a better situation
and a better place for her
to be than
with me in a in a police station you
know with with guardia all the time
um but it was heartbreaking i
held myself together through all of that
um
so not to to not frighten hair really
and not to to scare her you know i just
couldn't
believe
what i was what i was where i was what
was happening you know what how could i
have thought you know i was starting to
understand
you know where
at what point did i think that this was
okay
you know where in my mind did i think
that it was
okay to come to venezuela
smuggling drugs with my three-year-old
child and then i was like realizing as
well
you know that i'd just been used that
i'd been manipulated and that now this
was the consequences and this was the
situation that i was in and that
you know it wasn't just me that was
suffering it was you know my my daughter
who had no choice to play you know in
any of this and this was happening to
her as a direct consequence of of
my actions
how much was in that suitcase
it was
this is funny
um it was
it was five kilos
but then
might have even been more than that
actually there was so many bricks in
there it was like
there was like maybe six bricks in the
bottom of it and then you know six
bricks hidden in the top of it as well
but by the time i went to court
um it was like three kilos i think so
a couple of kilos went missing like from
there from the day of me being caught at
the airport to the damie me going to
court yeah a couple of kilos of it went
missing
yeah so so i go to court i don't know if
i have
a trial i you know i don't want it's
it's all you know the whole thing
happens in spanish with this
translator next to me that's badly
translating things
and i'm given some papers
which they're all in spanish
um
and i come back and
um
i show some of my papers and they tell
me that i've been to court i've been
charged with
um
possession of three kilos of cocaine and
trying to export her out of the country
i am and i pleaded guilty to her and
that i've been sentenced to ten years in
prison
so i go to san antonio which is the
prison in margarita
and
it's just crazy um it's it's it's mixed
prison as there's men and women there
before i've even got in on the roof of
the prison
because there's all there's men on the
roof
patrolling the prison with guns like
across their chests you know hanging
down like shotguns
and they look really rough like they're
not in they're not in uniform and you
know they're they're top bless and
they've got civilian clothes on
and
i'm just thinking you know it's i can't
i'm trying to figure out what's going on
um
and i find out later on that they're
they're prisoners
you know they're they're that's not
national guards you know patrolling the
roof out to actual prisoners
so basically how it goes is
you've got the women's bet and then
you've got like three separate men's bet
but in their
in the morning the gates open up at
i don't know eight o'clock in the
morning
and
everybody just mixes freely
like and you can go anywhere you want in
the in the prison it's not really
policed it's not really patrolled
all the guardia are there for is to make
sure nobody gets out
and then what goes on inside it's the
same
dealings i think as what goes on outside
there's you know there's drug deals you
know there's big drug deals going on you
know the the guardian are bringing in
you know drugs that they've confiscated
from the airport probably where my
couple of kilos went actually back in
the prison
they're the guardian themselves are
doing deals with
you know prisoners there's a like a boss
prisoner that's like running things um
so there's
there's rivalry going on between you
know different gangs the first night
that i was there
i woke up in the morning and there's so
this
this sirens going off and at first i
thought it was like
you know the morning bali and to wake
you up and get you out
and then i hear like loads of the
venezuelan women you know crying and
screaming and i'm told that this siren
what it means is that someone's been
killed someone in the in the prison has
been killed and then not long after you
hear in you know gunshots
like one day there was this war and it
went on for
like
three three days
um
and i think it or you know the women
aren't really that privy to the politics
of the the men's staff but i think it's
all to do with because when men come in
they get put on a certain side so i
think it all depends
you know from what gang they've come
from from from the streets we weren't
allowed like normally the women's brick
gets opens up in the morning and they
they didn't open our bit up but one of
the men's side was like right next to
ours and there were these big holes in
the wall i mean like holes the size of
doorways
and they were bringing they were
carrying the
like the injured and the dead through
this wall which was then coming through
our bed
and this was going on
i don't know
24 hours a day it just didn't stop for
three days and the
it was so intense you've got a thousand
men you know trying to kill each other
and you've probably got about 20 guardia
you know maybe a few more outside so as
long as the men aren't trying to get out
of the prison the guardian just like
left them to it the internal guards have
all locked themself away they're just
nowhere to be seen they've locked
themselves in their in their offices you
know they're keeping out the way they're
they're keeping safe and the
ambulance from the from the hospitals
outside that you know they can't they
can't come in you know they get their
their to the point where they're just
refusing to come to the to the prison i
think until it's over because they
they can't come in and get the bodies
out because everybody's killing each you
know there's just gun there's just
bullets just flying
everywhere
um
and then this went on for three days
until
i think eventually they just wore
themselves out or maybe even run out of
ammo i don't know
you think it's all over
but then the guardian come in and there
it's off because you know they need to
exercise their authority again you know
this situation they weren't able to
contain it so now they need to
show that you know actually that they
are in control so then they start
beating the men
and torturing the men
um
there's like this courtyard
and they get all their the men and they
get them i think it's like 10 o'clock in
the morning and they get all these men
like all thousands of them and they just
strip they strip them naked
and it's this tarmac courtyard and then
they make them all lie down on the on
the tarmac i think they made them lay
there until about eight o'clock at night
so from 10 o'clock in the morning till 8
o'clock at night and uh
you know the boiling system like
literally it's on the equator almost
under that sun and the guardian they've
got these huge swords they've not got
pointy ends on them they're like rounded
ends and when they see any of the men
you know trying to you know move because
they're
being burnt alive um you know they've
got these swords and then they're like
beating them you know with with with the
swords
so how did it feel being in the prison
witnessing all of that
it was
i think for the first
for the first year
every day i would think
i don't know why i thought i was
any different to anybody else
but in my mind i'd be saying to myself
like it's okay the embassy again and my
embassy are going to come tomorrow and
get me out of here and i there was
english girls that have been in there
four and a half years so i don't know
why i thought i was any different to
them but i think it was just a coping
mechanism i think at that point if my
mind had actually processed what was
going on i don't think my mind could
have coped with that
it was like watching a movie but the the
most realistic movie i've ever seen you
know because i couldn't comprehend you
know as a westerner
i couldn't
comprehend that
this is this is real this is going on
so how long did you spend in that prison
uh i think i spent
about 18 months
in that prison
yeah
18 months um
[Music]
did you get transferred after that did
you ask for a trunk yeah i asked for
transfer and i tried to kill myself
i think it was about
yeah
yeah just
about about 18 months in i think i
finally
accepted one day like
this is real this is happening i i can't
cope with this
um
[Music]
it's just seeing
these things going on you know every day
you know people being
tortured you know people being killed
you know people
hanging from just it was just too much
and
and you know a day came and it was like
okay this this is real this is happening
and you know and i did accept that
you know
the embassy aren't going to come
tomorrow and take me out of here
and when i came round i was unconscious
for a while
and when i came round um
i came around with it with a kind of
different mindset i was like okay so
this is happening this israel
i should be dead and i'm not i have to
deal with this
so then you got transferred to another
prison what was that like
yes the next person i went to was mixed
prison again
so my heart sank when i got there and
saw
you know men walking around i knew
like instantly when i got there i could
see and i was like okay this there's men
and women i know what this is going to
be like
and there was there was violence again
but just not nothing not to the level of
like the first place and
we didn't really
didn't really see it we saw the guns and
the and the knives and you'd hear we'd
hear it sometimes we'd hear the gunshots
there wasn't a siren there so you know
we wouldn't know if someone had been
killed until unless someone told us but
it wasn't a daily occurrence and there
weren't like huge
wars going on over there like there was
in the first one
when you were in all of those prisons
what was going through your mind
it was it was the whole time it was my
daughter the the whole yeah the whole
time that i was there i was
thinking about my daughter i
was
i was so ashamed of myself
and i was carrying so much
guilt
and
i just wanted to get home
and
start a new life for myself and for my
daughter you know
up to that point my life had just been
so chaotic and i'd never really
been interested in wanting or
knew how to do anything different and
and whilst i was in these prisons you
know i was making the decisions and
learning and growing that when i got
back you know i wanted to get a job i
wanted to get a good job i wanted to get
my daughter i wanted to get a mortgage
you know i wanted to
to be like a normal person of society
something i'd never you know
really paid attention to before i
started having a relationship with her
with a prison guard
jose
and
um and we fell in we fell in love with
each other me with him and and and him
with me
you know just as we were starting to to
fall in love you know he said to me
jokingly he said to me like oh you know
maybe one day i can help you escape from
here
and then
we'd been together probably i think
we've been together about
about
two years
and
i got david i was entitled to dave
releases
and he helped me get my day releases um
i had to like pay judges and pay
solicitors and had to pay people outside
of the prison to say that they were
going to offer me work and they were
going to offer me somewhere to stay and
so we sorted all of all of their site um
the the first thing was to
get across the border to colombia the
prison was four hours away from
colombian border
so like the first stage was just get to
colombia because once i'm in colombia
that there's
i'm not wanted in colombia that you know
if i'm in venezuela
i'm i'm a dane you know i could be
anywhere and a guardian could recognize
me or a police person and and that's it
you know i'm gonna get arrested and go
back to prison um i left the prison in
the morning as if i was going to do a
day release jose had just finished his
shift like that night
so i left first in the morning and i got
the bus
down to the village
and then
i made my way to this
bus station where i'd arranged to meet
jose where we were going to then meet up
together and travel together
across the colombian border
none of it went to plan on the day we
had all this route set
and that night the day before i was
going out that night it like rained so
much there was like avalanches like
honestly it was crazy there was
avalanches on the roads i was supposed
to be taken and i couldn't get down
certain roads because there were these
massive boulders and like rivers that
had like burst their banks and you know
so all these roadblocks that i'd like
planned to go through it's just oh you
know i had to get off one bus and try
and get on another bus and
i think through pure
like
willpower you know the universe was
definitely on my side that day i made it
to the to the best station where um
i met with jose
and he had a work colleague with him he
was a friend of ours that had come with
him as well to try and keep him calm
because we're all quite nervous we
shared a taxi with some other people
and when we got to the border
i just pretended i was asleep i was in
the in the back of the taxi and i had a
blanket all over me i remember it was
cold that night and i had a blanket over
me and i just pretended i was asleep and
i heard the guardian like asking the
people in the taxi where where they
would go in
and the people that we were traveling
with they just and they didn't know they
had no idea like the people we were
traveling with we didn't tell them oh by
the way we're escaping now i'm escaping
from jail
and as soon as i saw the sign that says
like bienvenido or colombia like welcome
to colombia
my heart just started doing somersaults
like i knew i knew that i was
i was home free you know even though i
was still in south america
i was safe then you know there's
nothing could be done to me in colombia
i'm not going to get arrested i'm not
going to go back to jail i'm not going
to get shot at for trying to escape
you know i'm kind of
almost home free
did you get back to the uk after that
i knew that if i could get back to
england
i'd get help from the government i
explained to jose look if i can get back
to england you know the the government
will give me somewhere to
you know give me somewhere to live and
they'll give me some money and just
until we can sort ourselves out and get
ourselves jobs and
and do better than what we're doing here
so
um
i didn't know what my legal stasis was
so i phoned
the foreign commonwealth office in
london
this was bizarre
and asked them what would happen like if
i come back to the to the uk what's
what's my status you know are you gonna
extradite me to venezuela to finish my
sentence you know am i gonna have to do
some
prison time there in the uk
you know what's what's the score
and
they didn't even know the venezuelan
government had not even communicated and
had not even told the english government
that i had escaped jail and the foreign
commonwealth commonwealth office were
like well
what do you want about natalie you know
honestly you've got another five years
to do
and i said to them like do you do know
that i'm not in prison don't you and
they were like what do you mean you're
not in prison i was like you do know
that i haven't been there for like i
think it was like six months and they'd
communicated with venezuela and
venezuela had said
as long as i didn't go back to venezuela
for the duration of my sentence
they weren't interested in me
and
england had said that because i hadn't
committed
the crime in england
then um
they also weren't interested in me so i
was completely
free to go back to england
jose came with me
we went back and
um
i got work pretty much straight you know
i was so
focused i was just like i was a
different
person you know the
the natalie that had
left england and gone to venezuela was
just not that you know it was just
somebody
unrecognizable to this person that i was
now
and and i was
yeah i was so
focused there was just nothing that was
getting that was going to get you know i
just
broke out of jail in venezuela you know
and that really empowered me as well
because i thought if i if i can do that
then i can
i can achieve anything so if i can do
that then i can come back to england and
i can get a job and i think within i
think like within within a week i had a
job with a friend of mine that was um
help me
and then within a month i had a really
good job i was in a working in a
recruitment agency as a as a consultant
and i think within a year i bought i
bought a house i had a mortgage
um
you know nikita back with me
had my job had jose
just it was just a different life had
nothing to do with drugs
i wrote a book
about my experiences
um and
published a book and i had a at that
point um
i was working i'd left my job at the the
recruitment consultancy and i was
working for
the clergy doing their financial
services
administration
and when my book came out
i had i did lots of publicity and i was
in the papers a lot and in the radios
and
on a couple of tv things
and um
yeah i got called into the office and um
questioned on it and
um
yeah i lost my job through a conflict of
interests was that was the reasons
which kind of threw me because i just
like i was i wasn't expecting that like
at all you know i had such good
intentions with everything when i came
back and i had this kind of blind faith
in in everybody and in the universe i
think then like i had a good job i'd
been paying you know lots of money in
tax i was paying you know i was on a
good salary and i was paying like 700
pounds a month in taxes so i kind of
felt as well that i was due a little bit
back because i was you know stuck but i
was told in their benefits office that
because i owned my own house and it was
mortgage that i actually wasn't entitled
to any benefits and that they wouldn't
like give me money to like pay the
mortgage and they told me that i had to
i had to lose my house i had to have my
house repossessed and i had to be
homeless on the streets with my kids and
then that if i went to them then then
they would put me up in some housing
and it just felt so unfair as well you
know i tried so hard to like
play the game and do the right thing and
i just felt like i was just completely
just being like screwed over
so
um
i started telling drugs again i didn't
know what else to do you know a lot of
my lots of my friends
um at the time you know were taking you
know party drugs
and i just wanted to pay my bills and
keep her a roof
over my head and i just didn't know
you know
what other options there were for me
there were no other options it was that
or
you know become homeless on the streets
with my kids
so i started selling drugs again to pay
their to pay the the bills to keep the
roof
over our head and
um i got caught
yeah as you do
uh i think i'd been doing it maybe a few
months
i got caught and i got another prison
sentence in the in the uk
uh and lost everything anyway i went
into prison with
lots of things and just you know house
car and walked out you know
years later with just a
backpack on my back with some with some
clothes and that was that
how did it feel to be back in the prison
system again
unfair
yeah it felt really unfair i was
i was i was really i was really angry
yeah i felt like um
i felt like i didn't deserve it
um
i felt like
the
the government was just
i felt like i was kind of set up to fail
you know and that that this that the the
government is almost like setting people
up to fail
as well because i thought i've tried so
hard to get out of a situation and i was
doing the right things and then actually
you know you
i was i felt like i was being i just
felt like i was being completely um
screwed over
and yeah i went into prison as a really
really angry angry person
yeah feeling like um
you know like i'd been
let down really
i tried to play the game and i you know
when i got a house and i
you know got a good job and actually you
know it's got me nowhere so i just chose
to live life outside of the system and
decide to live you know off-grid and in
caravans and
you know in communities and um you know
work festivals and
and just work and just live you know a
completely
different life outside of of the system
you know i i'm never going to i never
want to give them a penny
what are your relationship with your
daughter now and how do you feel about
everything you two went through
we're really open
like with each of there's no secrets at
all you know i know that
my daughter can can tell me anything and
and she knows that she can come and tell
me you know anything without
any judgment
like the venezuela thing she
she doesn't hold any grudges about it
she knows a bit about she knows about
what i was up to and the things then and
she also feels quite relieved that it
happened to me she thinks that if i
hadn't gone to venezuela that and then
you know i'd probably
be dead
how do you feel about your life now uh i
feel really fortunate
i feel really blessed i feel
i don't want to say
lucky because i didn't win a lottery
ticket and it come and land on my lap i
had to i had to go and get it
um but i
i feel that these things that i've gone
through in the past have taught me
you know how resilient i can be and have
taught me you know that i can survive
and they've taught me i'd know that i
can step into the unknown and try
something different
and i think through that path you know
i've found this place at the moment that
i'm you know i'm really happy i'm
surrounded by really nice people it's
very zen it's very calm
um and i feel like you know this
everything i've gone through in my life
has has led me to this place that i'm in
[Music]
if you ever have to flee an airport
don't run out of departures because
that's we're expecting
you to go go down to arrivals because a
lot of other people
coming in there it's always a floor
under under the purchase